こんにちははじめしゃちょーですすいませ
ん突然こんな動画を撮って何だよって思う
方がいらっしゃるかもしれませんが一応僕
の身に起きたこととして動画にさせて
いただきますはいこういうことがあったよ
というので何かの注意喚起になれればいい
かなとも思いつつ動画を撮ってますよかっ
たら聞いてください動画のタイトルにも
ある通りですね最近高速道路で本当に
死にかけました
はいもうこれは
森なくもうなんて言えばいいんだろうな
あんまり正直覚えてないんですよ衝撃的
すぎてあったことがなので淡々とちょっと
とりあえず何が起きたかということで
ちょっと話させていただきます本当はもう
昨日ぐらいにあったことなんですけども
あの撮影で
撮影場所から家に帰ってたんですよ高速
道路でだいたい僕んちから1時間ぐらいの
場所で撮影して
撮影が終わって帰ってる時の話なんです
けれども高速道路って降り場があるじゃ
ないですか高速道路が下道に変わるその
降り場の分岐みたいなところでもうお家に
着くぐらいだよっていう時にですね
高速道路で
タイヤが取れました
もう
ね面白みたいな感じだと思うんですけど
全然面白くないんですよマジでタイヤが
取れて高速道路でタイヤが取れた車自体は
僕の
初めてシャツの車なんですけども運転して
たのがちょっと僕ではなくですね後輩の
サーベンちょっと運転してもらってまして
撮影終わりだったので
俺とけいすけとサービス3人で撮影に行っ
ててで俺と見識がもう撮影でクタクタで
ちょっともうだいぶ運転危ないなぐらい
だったのでちょっと元気だったサーベルに
運転してもらおうと思ってさらに売ってし
てもらってたんだけどタイヤ取れてね
タイヤ取れましたでそのただタイヤが
取れるわけじゃないんですよ最近僕の車
点検してもらっててもうタイヤの空気圧と
か車の整備場とか全くなかった状態でして
どう考えても突然タイヤが高速道路で
取れるわけないんですよその僕が普通まあ
運転してて右車線を走ってたんですけど
追い越しの方を走っててまあ普通の
スピードで普通に走ってたんですけど
めっちゃ行ってもねゆっくり走って
先に終わってるから全然急いでとかないん
です普通に普通にマジで普通に走ってて
まあ簡単に言うと物が落ちてて物が落ちて
て
踏んでしまって
タイヤが取れる事態タイヤが取れてしまっ
たんですよ
すごかったよね
すごかったです
全然悪くないのよ一応そのパンクパンクな
のかなあれ
バースト
バーストだねパンクではないよね
運転してて何かを踏んで車ばっかり跳ねて
俺が目を覚まして
はいと言ってしばらく走ってたんですけど
もその踏んだ左側の後ろのタイヤかな左側
ですね左の後ろのタイヤがなんか変な音し
だしてキュルキュルキュルキュルってで
なんか焦げ臭くて左俺見たんですよ
助手席に乗ってたからで左のサイドミラー
で見たらタイヤがもうぐにゃぐにゃって
なっててうわっやばいこれパンクしてると
思ってとりあえず路肩に泊まろうと
危ないからすぐ左に寄って
止まろうって言って
止まったらホイールからタイヤが取れて
コロコロ転がっていきました
衝撃だった
衝撃だよね
難しいです
起きないから普通そうですね皆さん分かり
ますか高速道路で
タイヤが取れる恐怖人生で経験したこと
ないもんパンクすらあんまりしたことない
からないのよ初めてのそのタイヤ取れる
現象が高速で起きてテンパっちゃったん
ですけどとりあえずすぐ車を路肩にがーっ
と寄せてでまずとりあえず運転手運転手と
車に乗ってる人の安全確保が大地という
ことで6型の高速道路のなんか
ガードレールがあってその外に逃げて
警察と保険の会社に連絡して対応して
もらったんですけども天気が今保険屋さん
に連絡して車のロードサービスの処理をし
て
もらってるすごいねこんな大変なのね
ちょっと時間経ってるんであれですけど
その時の当時のこと思い出すとマジ怖かっ
たです
ちょっと避けきれなかったら申し訳なかっ
たいやーそれねあの一応警察の方とお話し
しましてそういう違反とかではないんで
すってやんとこではないし点数も引かれて
ないでしょ引かれてないですでもちろん
その高速道路とか道路にそういうものを
落とすことが悪いので
完全にそのなんかね一応写真撮っときまし
たけどこういうものが乙って言ってたんで
すってでもこれをさ高速道路の速い速度で
運転しててさ
避けるって相当難しいことだと思うし
余計だと思ってるから後輪のタイヤが
パンクしてるのよ本当に
踏む意識せずに言ってたら多分善人で踏ん
でると思うんだ確かに後輪だから本人的に
は多分避けようとして後輪になっちゃっ
てるし
警察の方の話を聞くとちょっとこれは本当
に不運だというか
仕方ない部分が多いし別に寝不足とかでも
なかったでしょまあそうですねその日は寝
てからちゃんと僕は運転してたんでその
眠気その居眠り運転とかでもなく本当に
普通に走ってただけというかそれは
ちゃんと俺も見てたから一応その落とした
人が悪いけども前方不注意っていうこと
言われたけども
警察の人からするとちょっとこれは
どうしようもないねというか歳して知った
わけでもないから気にすることではないと
思う
よだって無理でしょ
ちょっと買わせなかったですねタイヤ
側にあったというか真ん中にドーンじゃ
なくて若干こうやっぱタイヤの隅にタイヤ
側にあったから
[音楽]
余計にも車線超えちゃうしみたいな左側に
あったんですよ
車が来てさ無理やり受けようとして当たる
と余計マジの事故になってたから
できる限りと言いますか
避けたら後ろだけちょっと踏んじゃった
感じなんですけどからもう俺も寝てたから
状況よくわかんないですけど最善の策だっ
たかなっていうその後ろのタイヤがパンク
してるとかいろいろミスター舐めた結果
多分ねサイズの坂を尽くしてくれたと思う
のよ
かけたけどないや本当に狭い
悪くないよ本当にすいませんいや物落とす
やつが悪いじゃん
持ち主が誰かもわからないし結構警察の方
も同情というかそれはどうしようもない
なっていう感じだったので
むしろよく運転してくれたなって俺は
いやいやされようと知らなくてよかった
ですね
死んだと思いましたあのね事故とかって
予期しないから起きるんですよ
良き行ってきたり先にわかってれば買わ
せるので高速道路でスピードも出るから
普通気をつけて運転する場所なんですけど
今回サービスのこういうのもあってなんか
高速道路って安全じゃない道な瞬間もある
んだと思いましたね物を捨てるって思わ
ないじゃないですか高速道路にパンクする
ようなものが全く俺も想像してなかった
状況だったのでなんか一つまた運転する時
に意識すべきことが増えたなと思って
ちょっと
免許を持ってたり高速道路運転する機会が
ある方ちょっと覚えておいてください
タイヤがぶっ潰れるようなものたまに落ち
てますぜひ本当にマジで気をつけて
くださいでねレッカー車もなかなかすぐ
来れるわけじゃないんですよその高速道路
の降り口の近くってことはそこまでその
降り口から行けないから俺たちがその車が
壊れちゃった場所に来るのにめっちゃ時間
かかって50分ぐらい
待つことになりました結果的に高速道路の
中に1時間ぐらい待ってたんですよ3人で
もちろんその警察の方とかいていろいろ
対応はしてくださったんですけれどももう
ね
怖いですねタイヤ取れるのはないですね
これだけ時間があったんでちょっと色々僕
見てたんですけどもホイールの周りだけに
若干タイヤのゴムの破片が付いててそこに
亀裂がちょっと入ってましてなので多分
その硬い金具みたいなやつをバーンて踏ん
だ時にタイヤがポカーンと破裂しちゃって
タイヤだけホイールから外れちゃって
転がってったっていう感じなんだと思い
ますいやー
怖かったっすねこれすぐ止まってなかっ
たらどうなったんだろうとかでも思うし
無理にかわさなくて
隣の車とかに激突しなかったのも良かった
しちょっと事故と言っても前方不注意
できるのかなっていうけど俺が多分運転士
でもそこまで意識できてなかったんだろう
なと思ってすごいなんか運転気をつけ
なきゃいけないなって改めて思いました
いやもう撮影でクタクタだったんですけど
も全部吹っ飛んじゃって疲れがもう
緊張と恐怖で高速道路で車止まっちゃうと
ああいう感じになるんだなって待ってる1
時間も怖かったですよもう車すごいそこで
走ってくんすよ高速道路がビュンビュン
それはそうだけど
炎天下でめっちゃ天気がいい日だったので
もう太陽もめっちゃ眩しくてあの警察の方
がすごい優しくてなんか水とか差し入れし
てくださったんですけどまぁちょっと
不運な事故だなというかいや本当に死に
かけたねちょっとなんかいま一度運転気を
つけようかなって思いました
さよなら俺の車
[音楽]
ちょっと